У цьому протитуберкульозному диспансері в Боярці, неподалік Києва,
лікуються понад 150 хворих на туберкульоз.
У багатьох - мультирезистентна форма хвороби.
Тобто медикаменти на них практично не діють.
Василю 68 років.
Майже все життя він був цілком здоровим чоловіком.
Про те, що має туберкульоз, довідався випадково.
Комісію проходив, знайшли очажок,
послали сюди.
Абсолютно нічого, окрім на цьому, на знімку.
Павлові майже 30,
вдома на нього чекають дружина та донька.
Він знає, де підхопив туберкульоз.
Знайомий, він вийшов з в'язниці,
і я узнав, що в мене вже,
підхопив, так би мовити, мультирезистентний вже від нього.
Ізолювати пацієнтів один від одного у цій лікарні неможливо.
Немає тут і необхідного устаткування для циркуляції повітря.
Важкі умови для боротьби з мультирезистентним туберкульозом.
Утім, найбільший ризик в іншому,
вважає лікар Володимир Шукатка.
В більшості випадків безпосередньо джерелом інфікування мультирезистентним,
хіміорезистентною формою туберкульозу є пацієнти,
які відриваються від лікування.
Найбільшу проблему складає те, що лікування тривале, це 20 місяців,
юдина може не витримати, навіть людина,
яка, скажімо так, настроєна на одужання.
20 місяців пити велику жменю препаратів дуже важко.
Ідеальне середовище для збудників хвороби –
місця масових скупчень людей,
там, де  холодно і куди не проникає сонячне світло.
Мікроби легко поширюються під час чхання,
кашлю чи просто спілкування.
Збудників туберкульозу легко побачити під мікроскопом – тут вони червоні.
Утім, аби відрізнити звичайний туберкульоз від резистентного,
необхідно чимало грошей і часу.
На встановлення остаточного діагнозу
можуть піти два місяці.
Доти - жодного індивідуального лікування,
тож пацієнт може заражати інших.
В лабораторії у Боярці можуть визначити,
чи є у туберкульозу стійкість до рифампіцину.
Цей антибіотик – один з найдієвіших медикаментів проти хвороби.
Результат тесту встановлює комп’ютер,
він стане відомий протягом кількох годин.
Утім, далі лише складніше.
Щоб визначити стійкість до інших антибіотиків,
потрібно виростити бактерії. А це триває тижні.
Хоча можна було б і швидше.
Завдяки сучасній технології генних тестів,
геном збудника можна розпізнати за лічені дні.
Однак це дуже дорого.
В Україні є усього чотири пристрої, здатні це зробити.
В цій лабораторії на такий поки чекають.
Але чому в Україні стільки резистентних штамів туберкульозу?
Експерти кажуть: окрім частого переривання терапії,
це пов’язано із системою охорони здоров’я.
Десятиліттями хворих на туберкульоз тримають у тісних диспансерах,
як тут, у Боярці.
Такий підхід давно наражається на критику,
зокрема, і з боку самих представників системи охорони здоров’я.
Багатоліжкові палати,
немає індивідуального знаходження,
пацієнти спілкуються один з одним,
і ми з вами поспілкувалися - ви мені передали свою резистентність А,
я вам свою передав резистентність Б.
У нас є підстави бути оптимістами,
у нас з’являються технології, у нас з’являються нові методології,
у нас з’явилися ресурси.
За роки епідемії туберкульозу в Україні
лише у 2016-му кількість захворювань на мультирезистентний туберкульоз
вперше пішла на спад.
Більш швидке встановлення діагнозу
та тривалий супровід пацієнтів в процесі лікування –
нове гасло у боротьбі з мультирезистентним туберкульозом.